IDO GREEN: Hello, everyone.
I'm Ido Green and I'm a
Developer Advocate.
DANNY HERMES: And I'm Danny
Hermes, Developer Programs
Engineer, working on the
cloud app engine.
And we're here to show you our
demo, which yesterday, it was
an offline demo.
It actually never wanted
to come online.
So if you want to see the full
talk, check out the link at
the bottom of this video.
The talk was "Mobile Web and the
Cloud, the Triple Crown of
Modern Applications".
And so here we go,
on to the demo.
Let's jump on to the device.
Let's see it, Ido.
IDO GREEN: Great.
So we have here a mobile
web application.
And first thing we need just
to authenticate our users.
So we sign in with G+, which
is extremely easy, and you
could check the code
on GitHub.
I'm accepting the confirmation
dialog here.
And now when I'm back, you
could see a few things.
One, the sign-in button
vanished.
And the app itself now made a
connection to the server and
brought us all the nice
pictures that we took
beforehand.
Now as you can see, I have
here this crucial
functionality to add photos.
And here natively, in the
browser, I can just click on
Take Photo.
And very nicely, I'll try
to give you a view
of what we are seeing.
And you could see that
the photo loaded.
I can just give it a name.
Google.
DANNY HERMES: Yeah, a great
photo of the studio we're
filming in.
IDO GREEN: GDL.
And I can save it.
Now when I was saving it, a
few things happened in the
background.
First thing, and the most
important one, is that we got
a confirmation first
that the photo
itself was saved locally.
Then we got a confirmation that
the photo was sent to the
cloud to our one source of
true that we want to have
there, so we could see it
on different devices.
DANNY HERMES: So if we switch
to the laptop, where our
wonderful user Wadsworth Testing
10 has already signed
in, and I refresh this page,
we wait a little bit and we
actually see that photo there
on another device.
So heading back to
the device--
IDO GREEN: Now let's take
it to the next level.
As we spoke yesterday, we want
to make sure that our app will
be productive and could let the
user work when we don't
have any connection, or we
have flaky connections.
So here I'll do something
quite brave.
And just remember that
we are in a browser.
I'm just now releasing
the connection.
And you could see up on the top
left corner that we have
the offline indicator, and
we are now offline.
And I can still go,
add a photo.
Take another nice photo
of our studio here.
And a few things will
happen now.
So I captured a photo.
I can give it a quick
name and a quick
description, and save it.
Now when I'm saving it right
now, you could see that on get
confirmation immediately
that the photo itself
is now saved locally.
DANNY HERMES: But if we switch
over to the laptop--
IDO GREEN: --the magic
will happen.
DANNY HERMES: --and we try to
refresh, we will see, we don't
have the photo yet.
But if we go back--
IDO GREEN: Now let's go
back to the tablet.
And you could see that then once
I'm switching and hooking
it back and giving it a
connection, first you see the
indicator on the top changing
from red to green and ready.
And now our photo is being
sent to the cloud.
DANNY HERMES: Sent
to the cloud.
So if we check out one last time
on Wadsworth Testing 10's
laptop, and we refresh it and we
wait a bit, we actually got
that connection back
and we see it.
So that concludes our demo.
Thank you for stopping here.
Again, I encourage you to
go see the whole talk.
But chances are, you actually
came here from
the original talk.
I hope you enjoyed this.
And we hope you'll check out
some of the other videos from
Google I/O.
IDO GREEN: Absolutely.
And check in the latest and
greatest in HTML5 [INAUDIBLE]
dot com, and build
amazing web apps.
Thank you.